257 quilômetros sete dias no deserto do
saara e calor muito calor
o desafio foi lançado por um colega
ao falar das suas aventuras nas nossas
montanhas e que me disse assim maradona
das raias tu não consegues e olhe bem
nos olhos e disse assim eu vou fazer e
sim com sua minha aventura no início de
2012 numa altura que eu nunca tinha
corrido
eu não sei pra final num cão que essa
atrás de mim eu sei porque as nossas
serras aumentar as distâncias para me
preparar e foram quatro anos sonho um
ano e maio de preparação intensiva para
este desafio
não vou a partir do dia 10 de abril
juntamente com mais mil 108
participantes dos quais 973 chegaram ao
final foi uma espera uma prova em auto
suficiência o que significa que nas
minhas costas ea roupa não era muito
mais do que o do corpo comida à base de
comida à disposição muito saborosa
importantes talvez assim o nível de
afeição tivemos ontem não é
alguns frutos secos e mais nada a
organização dava nos água apoio médico e
vamos também a nossa cara muito
confortável uns a cama para dormir no
chão é agradável e econômica que é o
chão com pedras do deserto e tudo neste
momento helinho na primeira etapa
à saída da primeira prova e nada ao som
da música de geisy disse highway to hell
banha propósito recusaram a semana é
caminhar várias horas muitas horas a
cada dia num calor abrasador
mas quando se começa uma coisa que foram
durante tanto tempo
apenas temas essenciais uma energia
imensa hidrante que os primeiros dois
quilômetros tudo a gente corta em lucro
com suas famílias prendas do pai natal
quando eram os mil dias ao fim de 2
volto com os kiwis nestas costas e já
não conseguir remar mais ainda faltavam
255 como é que ia ser bom
os dois quilômetros seguintes não faz há
três áreas lindíssimas do neste mês
julga acompanhados de uma simpática
tempesta deraa é que nos importava com a
sigla do na baixo é certa e criar chegar
ao primeiro posto de controlo já se via
na cara assustada de várias pessoas
mas o que é isto windows 7 chegará ao
final do dia e subir as mensagens que
família e os amigos diziam em viagens
isto porque mesmo que isso leve
telemóvel não há redes portanto não há
forma de comunicar com a família e
amigos quer ir para uma fila
interminável de esmaltes não é não foi
propriamente a minha opção é também
muito interessante perceber que duas ou
três chips palavras até de uma pessoa
que nós não conhecemos alguém que diz a
campanha no facebook ou alguém que é
amigo da alga é nos manda e nós lemos
não se não é sempre foi a 4 o look que o
time tem se dado que é pra nós sentir
aquelas palavras aquilo que mourinho é
que o acompanhamento do fato
apesar de perceber estamos sós estão
sempre acompanhados ao fim deste dia já
havia muita gente pensava e com bolhas
de água nos pés os meus ainda estavam
bons princípios haia e até levá se mal
até começar o segundo dia o segundo dia
foi o dia do desespero usada para lhes
rir eu acho que eu fui mesmo sob a
fotografia o que aconteceu como farão as
bolhas nos pés não era uma nem duas eram
17 neste e 8 neste algumas das senhoras
e que já foram mais
então vocês vão perceber o que estou a
dizer é do é como se tivesse ter um
filho não um mas dois um pouco de pé e
espero que não falte patifes
então é interessante que chegamos assim
o pensamento bo fazenda técnicos frito e
paguei minha inscrição não deve nada a
ninguém
quem gosta de mim vai continuar a
prestar
quem não gosta juiz eu posso desistir
após ficar o próximo posto e desistir
só que no momento em que este pensamento
se concretiza aqui dentro de mim começa
uma dor muito maior
é dor daninha alma e eu percebia que o
momento que se não vo até o fim senão
força mas impôs em alma vai doer não
esta semana não hoje não escalar o resto
da minha vida e encenador
eu não estou disposta a passar o curso
vai doer sem vai doer hoje vai doer esta
semana vai do scala durante os próximos
três semanas enquanto eu recupere mas a
minha alma e não estou disposta aquela
do am
então é interessante que automaticamente
as duas espécies desaparecem
entretanto como não ser preconceito
facto relativizar e definir
automaticamente com a execução as
prioridades já não é prioritário alertar
o comprador do pé é prioritário que ela
desapareceu fugir da dor da alma mas
estou obrigou algum trabalho de gestão
este tempo nesta prova nós temos que
gerir o alimento há água todos os
recursos que temos que acompanhar os
todos nós sinais fisiológicos e isso fez
com que para o terceiro dia e criar uma
estratégia uma sequência que curtia é
cada quilômetro destes 37 porque nesse
dia não era assim
os primeiros 200 metros por cada
quilômetro
fazia um checape físico como é que um
cinto e pensava mentalmente como é que
um sente nos pés nas pernas no tronco
nas costas como estão as minhas opções o
que eu estou a pensar a sentir agora é
que se passa aqui dentro dos primeiros
200 metros nos 200 metros seguintes
uma técnica de respiração do yoga para
ajudar a manter a temperatura do corpo
baixa é tão eram 200 metros sempre
respirar de uma forma é assim e
simpático city mas pronto quem faz uma
coisa destas também não se importa muito
com isto parece né então 17 minutos e
200 metros respirar desta forma os
semestres seguintes serão os mais
agradáveis porque eram os segmentos de
turismo então nesse momento êxito quanto
estava a passear por uma rocha em uma
cela fez gravar os vídeos falava com o
companheiro do lado 100 metros prova por
mais uns 500 metros seguintes já o
mantra um sonho repetitivo que fizesse
com que o meu pensamento estiver só na
cansou não pensassem mais nada diz
heraldo jet e pontiac parte que ponte
epa deste foi o centro do time vivo ea
minha mente não divulgar as próprias
coisas
isso ajudou é conseguir gerir os
recursos é conseguir manter o foco no
crescente a cada ecofin de caná custo
controla a fim de cada etapa e assim
cheguei muito é sentir muito melhor no
final do terceiro dia do no final do
primeiro single grande desafio
o dia longo a prova de 84 quilômetros
pra qual tem os 36 horas ou 34 para
terminar em primeiro no grande recife pe
meia distância até então que tinha
proferido eram 43 quilômetros
eu não sou eu porque há uma distância
muito maior como já tinha cerca de 120
nas costas
vamos ver como é que a scor estratégia
já que foi eu tenha que arranjar forma
de chegar rapidamente aos primeiros
postos de controlo tudo tem para mais
apertado então é arranjar um par de
pernas tivesse um ritmo suficientemente
rápido e insuficientemente lento porque
não conseguir correr nesta altura com os
vossos rapidamente afirmar posto
assim foi o clima nas costas de uma
senhora britânica como rui semedo mora
ao final do primeiro posto
é isso farão dela uma vez mais contínuo
então ao longo desta desta manhã dizem
cerca do meio dia quando o sol estava
mais alto estava entre a segunda ea
terceira etapa atravessar um deserto
tanto a nível acho que o mais plano do
que este palco eram laxi kuhn e isso tem
lá ao fundo o próximo posto de controlo
sobre por ser um filme flor é que a
pessoa anda anda e não sai do mpe city e
anda e anda e não sai do mesmo sítio
então isto começa a gerar aqui uma certa
loucura uma certa angústia nação e da
altura o varejo ao meu lado
estes dois serviços faz monstruosos 1241
deste lado quem eram essas criaturas
eram os meus medos os meus medos tomaram
vida eo vilseck exatamente ao meu lado
por um lado o medo de falhar o medo não
chegar ao fim já tinha passado por isso
no passado e não estava disposta a
passar por essa dor outra vez mas de
situado em aumento da saúde sim e
criticar o fim mas queria chegar ao fim
bahia não era chegar ao fim numa maca o
teco vassoura criticar bem fisicamente
ficar aquela turma o próprio pé
então foi importante perceber que não
estes duas escrituras elas podem adoro
isto vai ajudar a avançar e isso vai
ajudar a tirar a tensão a que estou a
fazer
são 10 mil aos médios e três anos
o deserto um pouco mais à frente pois
desse lado e por volta do quilômetro 30
numa das poucas sombras que apreciam os
arbustos do deserto em todas esta altura
todos mesmo que gentili no chão uma
forma de conseguirmos encontrar uma uma
sombra agradava e que havia umas rochas
e nestas rochas tínhamos alunos
participantes a descansar e um deus a
ser assistido uma senhora ser assistida
quando uma próxima
estava com equipamento que estava sendo
regado a sur estava ali a história roupa
ea mulher lá com garrafas d'água
ela tava ter um choque do calor as
coisas que acontecem vários
participantes nesta prova se não tem
cuidado com a sua hidratação com a
gestão dos seus sinais fisiológicos e
sabem quem é esta senhora pois era a
mesma senhora que manhã o hotel primeiro
posto
então foi muito interessante porque esta
senhora que nem concordo nem o número
dela e ela mostrou com com a em vida
mostrou no ser humano estes dois meses
que trabalharam comigo que o lado
de manhã ela de um dos cidadãos para
chegar rápido para não falhar mas
naquele momento ela mostrou olha se isso
não tem os cuidados não observamos o teu
corpo diz tu vais acabar assim
então foi um momento de reflexão
interessante o fato é fundamental que
nós em todos os desfiles todos os
desertos que a vida nos traz que haja
sempre esse equilíbrio
olhavam lado olhar pro outro e avançar
no mais desta desta fina corda buttons
do quilômetro 30
o dia continua a noite cai e cansaço
começa a pular da meia noite e meia
noite e chega a um quilômetro 55 posto
de controlo ou 5 um céu estrelado lindo
de morrer assim
e diz pronto vida obrigada postou a eles
são lindos de morrer eu vou ficar
estou grata e assim fiquei uma hora saí
me consegui me mexer
o fim desta hora desse bom parece não
foi esta o ter que fazer isso até o fim
não é
caramba é tão larga vantagem a muito
custo e estes últimos 30 km foram fatos
a passo de caracol
cada posto contratava 10 quilômetros e
de mais 33 horas é fazer com que a
distância de 10 quilômetros
eu penso que tenho o meu filho mais novo
na altura com cinco anos teria feito
mais depressa do que eu então é
interessante tanto o meia noite mais uma
vez um ciclo ano mas desta vez feito
pedrinhas
com tantas pedrinhas que mesmo que
fossem pontinhos bailarina não conseguia
não acertar uma pedra ea sessão é com
que alguém que está enfiar canivete com
os pés não é um nem dois do tipo sim um
monte uma uma um conjunto de canivete
que deva ser um comportamento dos pés
o documento sozinho nesta altura os
participantes atuam todos espalhados
neste seu estrelado lindíssimo lausitz
out luz acompanhado apenas de duas
holdings brancos que são domingos-se
nada assustador é nada assustador e
pessoas simples mas servir às
gargalhadas cheia de dor e começamos
como é que é possível ter tanta dor e
tanto prazer ao mesmo tempo e não era
nenhum ritual saibamos que está tensa
era mesmo a dor eo prazer e sim foi
avançando até chegado a linha discada
deste longo
esses são de cortar aquela meta é de uma
intensidade não receber uma força ao fim
de 26 horas e alguns minutos é percorrer
o deserto quando se corta aquela linha
de chegada parece não aconteceu nada e
precificamos repente frios que nenhum
mal faz preparados por dia seguinte
e este seguinte foi o dia de prova da
maratona de 42 quilômetros em que chama
de conquista conquista porque tu podes
fazer 84 42 é passado no parto vôlei já
vai e portanto conseguir passar muito
bem e ele sempre será a nossa capacidade
de adaptação
o episódio todo o esforço apesar de
todos os quilômetros que já tem em cima
apesar de dormir no chão e comer esta
comida de tomar banho com maio litro de
água e é possível tomar banho com uma
letra d água e ficar uns quebrou e do
link inscrever
foi um dia interessante foi passado com
este senhor americano nunca mais vou ver
nela mim e portanto podemos contar cada
momento da história de vida um ou outro
porque lá a vontade que nós temos quando
sabemos nunca mais vamos encontrar esta
pessoa na nossa vida
os prêmios
[Risadas]
a última etapa nos 17 quilômetros da
prova da unicef da prova de
solidariedade finalmente perfeição são
de tudo o que se passou nestes sete dias
tudo o companheirismo com os
compatriotas portugueses da tenda 9 tudo
choro de toda a alegria tudo em me se
dão demissões que foram acontecendo
súbito toda a preparação que eu senti
que esta prova trouxe para os muitos
desert e certamente a vida vai trazer e
todos nós passamos então a sessão quando
entregam aqui
esta amiga esta medalha que apesar de
ter ficado em 800 e qualquer coisa para
me salvar o mandala dor porque conquista
pessoal é essa sensação de que sim é
possível sim isso que parte é possível
nós conseguiram avançar nós conseguirmos
conquistar todos os nossos os nossos
sonhos
todos os nossos desafios por mais duro
que os possam ser por mais complexo por
mais desagradáveis sejam estes momentos
que a vida nos traz nossa família nossos
profissionais é possível é possível mas
se pararmos é possível avançar ambos
conquistaram de dar trabalho da é
preciso fazer opções
claro que sim uma boa doce estão 100 a
cada momento a cada minuto
mas é preciso criar acreditar que
aconteceu e sentir permitir que esta
força que vivem nós em cada um de vós
conta tanto quanto eles façam avançar
superar
tudo com muita humildade pois das outras
coisas que eu aprendi aqui é que apesar
de nós temos estes seres evoluídos temos
esta tecnologia fantástica
nós continuamos a ser propriedade da mãe
natureza nós aqui temos esta mãe
natureza este sítio não quer que seja
que a gente vai ganhar voltar
então ao mesmo tempo temos esta força
mas temos esta humildade e é capaz ela
que eu posso criar tudo que nós
quisermos criar faça uso de vossa força
sejam muito humilde dos anjos bons
sonhos
[Aplausos]